that's right
we're continuing minecraft and jurgen is
back i have to make some adjustments
but the sheep is back too hello sheep
epic
yeah again i swear to god stop escaping
why does he do this so a lot of you were
saying that
i can make like a lasso or leash or
something i will but apparently i need a
slime
so we're gonna go find some epic slime
no we're gonna go back to the pirate
ship we have a lot of epic stuff to do
today
but everyone kept saying oh there might
be another treasure map in the pirate
ship okay i'll go back
i'll go back gamers gamer speak i listen
vote pewdiepie
2020 gamer imagine a society run by
gamers
all right you're again i swear to god
i'm gonna go off
why is it white there oh god damn it
keeps happening
all right so if i save and then go back
he should
be there yeah okay so it was a glitch
and that was a glitch too everyone was
like oh how can he not understand it was
a glitch oh i'm sorry the game that has
been out for nine years
still has basic glitches in it oh god
it's getting dark no i can't do this
ah hey sugar oh
we're gonna make cake bros oh sorry
i think if we go along the seashore we
should find the ship
oh god creepers
it's fine gamers i'm not afraid
i feel like this is a terrible idea
oh god there's monsters everywhere
jurgen but as long as you're
you're close to me we'll be okay here
again
okay there it is found it oh god oh god
oh god oh god
oh perfect we'll put jurgen on the
plateau
stay stay
thank you so apparently it's really rare
to find a pirate ship
in like above the
water someone said i don't know people
can tell me anything
i'm supposed to look for a treasure map
oh god i'm drowning
god damn i'm bad at this game
what if there is a treasure map on this
boat
i'll find it so why can't i not breathe
underwater
what's the easiest way to find it maybe
going down i can't breathe that long
i'm not a fish where is that you guys
are trolling me again
god this takes forever come on it's so
obvious that that was it
because the only part that goes down too
all right after
mining uh the whole thing all night i
have the dudes that there is no
treasure map thanks gamers for nothing
it's fine we have other stuff to do it
doesn't matter it wasn't even important
let's get out of this
place here again
whoa dolphins that's epic
hey sheep we're back wow what an
adventure
go in jargon go in thank you i got the
hoses in the bear
dark wood how where did he oh god it
happened again
all right we may not have gotten a
treasure map
but at least we got a dark door
yeah look at that beautiful carpet it
looks so nice now
i know i know i know well well well
okay step two get gucci pants
all right who's the gucci mane you're
the gucci mane
why oh by the way i might steal that
looking for gucci guy where's the gucci
goddamn
such a failure what are you doing maybe
i give him
stuff i hate them i want them to die
they're gonna pay for this i can make
leather horse armor
what you never played super simile i can
make
armor for oh my god i can make armor
for for jargon jargon
look i have crescent for you oh you're
dark at night
let's lick you up cute shut up shut up
everyone quiet jurgen this is a special
moment
you're getting leather armor you look so
fancy dude
oh my god that's awesome
i love him let's go good night
okay jurgen wish me good luck we're
going to the nether
because everyone said there's a secret
achievement
if you sleep in the nether why would
anyone do that
oh god this place is so creepy dude why
on earth would i sleep here
this is awful all right fine we'll make
a little
nether realm house how about that it's
gonna be so cute
oh god i'm scared
all right good night gamer
my own audience
my own supporters can you believe this
scared me dude
i don't know what i was expecting but
not god
my house no
oh my god god ah
damn you give me back my stuff
dude if i don't get back my diamond
pickaxe
we're through okay i'm done
i just are better than this my house
blew up
are you kidding god damn it where is it
like half my stuff dude help me look pig
people
[ __ ] useless can i get how do i oh i
can chop away the flames
there we go go away cool i'm glad i
brought
back gaming week to get epically trolled
and lose half my stuff sleep in the
nether family
i missed i lost my pants do you feel
good about yourself
what's a block of quartz it looks pretty
i like it
god damn it i lost my shield too so
someone said
i can actually go to the nether round
with jurgen i just have to like
i want to see if that's possible
this seems like a terrible idea ah
you're against drowning
what no jurgen went through you're gonna
come back come back go back
god damn it god damn it you're getting
you crazy
all right so does the compass work here
no it doesn't great on second thought
no
what the hell
i gotta teleport your kid
no you're good get out of there get out
oh
no
he was here a second ago
maybe he went through to the other side
no no i'm not crying shut up
you are oh my god he left us way too
soon
jurgen was like a father to me
i loved him like my son you never know
when the ones that love you are gonna
leave you
i never thought this day would come he
left us too soon
rest in peace jurgen
rest in peace if i die fine i can
respawn
your again can't respawn i'm gonna have
to get your get number two
now of course now of course there can
only be one year again
but there's jurgen number two here you
go jurgen
have it all okay
hopefully this one hopefully jurgen the
second
won't be such an [ __ ]
i feel like i just bought myself a new
pet it will never be the same
i'm still hurting
wait there's one thing i want to do
here you go jurgen
he loved melons i'll plant the trees for
you jurgen
i'll plant as many trees all right
things happen we must move on we have
other things to do
okay we're gonna kill the ender dragon
let's go jurgy why does jorgen have more
life jurgen
the second oh i never been in the desert
before
there's bunnies there's freaking bunnies
can i put them in the bucket damn it
you're back
buddy what's up hello
what are you doing in the desert can you
go in the bucket
what where'd he go mysterious all right
i'm gonna have to kill some bunnies i'm
sorry look away children
look away children i'm sorry oh
oh whoa he's back what the hell what
well this place is cool
whoa another house what is that
it's got a creeper phase on it
what whoa
what is this
whoa whoa
whoa whoa what
my god minecraft if jurgen could see
this he'd be freaking out
yeah he better not run away this time
well that's
really deep oh it goes up as well that's
so cool
how do i go down there i'm scared
okay here we go
whoa oh no oh no i set off a bomb didn't
i
this episode sucks
minecraft
if i could take it all away
if i could do what they say
why did i do that i could have gone i
bet there was like awesome stuff in the
damn it some murderers
this is my evil arc beginning all right
if anything
else happens i'm gonna be
very angry
wow whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
i'm just confused by everything first of
all we need to get jurgen the second
back
second of all oh god what a day
you ever had a bad day in minecraft
you ever had a bad day well imagine
having a bad day in minecraft
okay okay i see here again
this good i thought this was a kids game
okay why are there actual traps in there
oh i got you now oh i got you now oh i
got you now
oh i actually got him oh no i'm sorry
my trusty horse jurgen the second my man
i missed you boobs thanks
i guess now we're gonna need a lot of
sand so we gotta go down again
god damn it there better not be any more
traps in here
oh my god
oh god of course there's a creeper there
as well
what are you doing go away oh my god
guys i am having a bad day okay
you're not going after oh my oh
all right we keep on gaming it's gaming
week
it's gaming week
and so he kept walking with no
armor no skill
and no hope he just wants jurgen bag
and all his stuff too would be great
play minecraft they said sleep in the
nether they said you can enter there
with your horse they said
i can never trust anyone ever again
not even myself at least jurgen ii
actually he's cool
here we go again i'm getting my stuff i
don't care
i'm getting my stuff maybe whoa what a
cool room
maybe but surely they're gone now
right look at the damage
all right if i find like a sword or
anything i'll take it
oh i see stuff down there oh my god
that's my stuff that's literally my
stuff
god oh god oh god let's just get this oh
god this is just the first stuff this is
not this
he dropped the bow come on come on come
on shirley
my diamond pickaxe is here
right
look at this explosion dude you can
all gone cool let's never do that again
epic did you find the treasure yes
what did it cost everything okay
okay you're getting pewds for more
adventures
i am genuinely upset over minecraft
oh god what has happened
is that another one or the same one
okay
no it's the same one is that another
shipwreck
it is isn't it damn it's far
your again will you be good that's how
we hunt
fishes in sweden hi yup oh my god it
worked
okay we're going to the uh pirate thing
and maybe
we finally get some good news this
episode god condemn it
there better be epic treasure oh this
one looks bigger
i see a treasure okay okay oh what is
this
whoa it's like an air hole
cool paper hey you want some paper
here you go felix oh there's another one
potatoes oh another one
whoa okay rich boy
rich boy i can get good she pants ow
ow okay epic
yeah again it was awesome
oh my god buried we found a treasure map
oh what do i do with it
what i do with buried treasure map sun
is setting
let's go back home jurgen it's been an
adventure
you're getting a second all right time
to go to sleep
i'll dream of jurgen the first
forever one thing that i'm curious about
is
yeah i hope you're dying what happens if
you build another nether portal in the
nether realm
question mark so let's uh explore that
question
okay i never actually done this
how do i do it
uh
what
i gamers here we go
oh [ __ ]
oh yeah gaming
time hey someone's shooting me this is
my gaming town
if i remember correctly i had an
obsidian down here
yep there it is let's be careful
because there's freaking lava everywhere
this is always fun
what the hell is that was a bat dumb bat
i would never make that mistake okay we
have ten
all we need baby now if we enter
the nether what up pig
and let's say we walk a bit
further god it's so hard to walk in here
where would i go either you guys have
nothing better to do
jesus christ dude oh my god
i'm so scared fine let's just build a
bridge
lives gives you lemons build bridges
over them
so what is that down there is that worth
mining
i wish i knew maybe i'll explode out of
nowhere
or we can just clog this
what's that sound
god i hate that sound
i think we can stop this as well
oh yeah no more lava don't worry piggies
i won't charge you
okay what is this
whoa this looks cool
wow all right don't walk on them got it
i can hold them i can't walk on them
i mean i guess it makes sense they're
hot dude there's so many uh what's
happening with the music
hello
a little too epic for my taste thank you
all right all right you can calm down
minecraft
magma block okay epic
why do i feel like my whole life is
flashing through my eyes
holy moly macaroni
petroni this better not kill me i'm
gonna be pissed
okay let's go
gonna happen i don't know that's the joy
of minecraft
so it does take me to another place
what
donkeys there's llamas in this game dude
they're so cute
ah no take me back to netherlands why is
there underwater things there
uh hello what
is it a glitch oh what
uh okay that's scary magma blocks oh god
they're slurping that's so confusing so
those lit up
oh my this is their lawn
this freaking lot don't explode my
llamas i will kill you
oh the shield can tank them oh they talk
to make noises
gun powder break freak freak freak
they're so cute i want to take you home
oh my god you're
so adorable oh my god they're still
coming for me
this one's got a bow dude
this is swamp monsters these guys are
strong dude
i want the llama what do they eat
so is there any way i can breathe on the
water easier whoa
what is this i don't know
there better not be traps that's all i
know this stays
oh there's a chest oh god
there better not be sharks in this game
then i'm quitting
oh i did it i just want the chest
are you kidding me that's it oh it's his
what blue eyes so if i kill him can i
steal his llamas
because i will do it
don't you spit on me okay i see a lot
more stuff to explore but i'm gonna
have to end this episode here guys
because i need the comments to help me
actually i can't trust you
smash like and i'll see you guys next
time
bye oh you never played two for
simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price